نعم في اخر المستجدات بيان مقتضى بصادر عن
قوات اليونيفيل هو يشير الى ان هذه القوات
التابعه للامم المتحده والعامله في جنوب
لبنان رصدت اطلاق مجموعه من الصواريخ من
جنوب البلاد باتجاه اسرائيل بيان اليونيفل
لم يذكر عدد هذه الصواريخ ولكنه اعتبر بان
هذا الامر هو امر خطير للغايه وان قائد
قوات ليتواصل معه الطرفين اي مع اسرائيل
ومع لبنان من خلال مكتب الارتباط بين
القوات الدوليه ولبنان واسرائيل في محاوله
لتخفيف من حدث التصعيد البيان بيان يونيفل
اشاره بشكل واضح الى ان الامور خطيره ويجب
على كافه الاطراف ان لا تتجه الى مزيد من
التصعيد لانه كما بات معلوما الان الجميع
يترقب هل ستقوم القوات الاسرائيليه قوات
الاحتلال باستهداف بعض المناطق الجنوبيه
التي تم اطلاق الصواريخ منها وهنا لابد من
الاشاره بان الخبر الذي اوردته الوكاله
الوطنيه للاعلام اللبنانيه والذي جرت به
على نطاق واسع عن قصف اسرائيلي استهدف بعض
المناطق اللبنانيه اتضح بانه غير دقيق
وغير صحيح وفق مصادر النيه لبنانيه على
اكثر من مستوى هي اكدت بانها حتى الان لم
يحصل اي قصف اسرائيلي للاراضي اللبنانيه
ولكن ما سقط داخل الاراضي اللبنانيه يعود
الى سببين الاول بعض الصواريخ التي تم
اطلاقها باتجاه اسرائيل بعضها لم يتجاوز
الحدود اللبنانيه باتجاه العمق الاسرائيلي
ولكنه سقط داخل الاراضي اللبنانيه وهذا
جزء من الصواريخ سقط في منطقه قريبه من
موقع اطلاقها
الامر الثاني يرتبط بان المضادات
الاسرائيليه والصواريخ اطباء الحديديه
التي اعترضت الصواريخ التي اطلقت من لبنان
ايضا بعض شظاياها وبعض قطعها المعدنيه
سقطت في الداخل اللبناني ومن هنا كان ثمه
ارباك على مستوى الوكاله الوطنيه الرسميه
اللبنانيه التي اشارت الى قصف اسرائيلي
ولكن من الواضح حتى وفق الجيش اللبناني
وفق مخابرات الجيش اللبناني في الجنوب بان
هذا الامر غير صحيح وغير دقيق على مستوى
القراءه العامه في لبنان لكل هذه التطورات
هي باتت تشير الى ان ما حصل عمليا هو
يندرج وان كان بوتيره اعلى من السابق
ولكنه ضمن نفط السياق الذي كانت تقوم به
الفلسائل الفلسطينيه عندما كانت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في شهر رمضان تقتحم
المسجد الاقصى والاماكن المقدسه وتعتدي
على المصلين كان غالبا ما تقوم الفصائل
الفلسطينيه من لبنان وتحديدا جنوب لبنان
باطلاق صواريخها باتجاه العمق الاسرائيلي
صحيح سابقا كانت الاعداد تكون متواضعه
بالنسبه لما حصل اليوم اليوم الصواريخ
ناهزت ووصلت الى 30 صاروخا ولكن بطبيعه
الحال المنطقه التي التقط منها طبيعه
الصواريخ الكاتوشه والجراد وايضا ما تم
اعتراضه وكيف لم تتمكن اجزاء كبيره من هذه
الصواريخ او كميه كبيره من هذه الصواريخ
من عبور الحدود هو يؤكد بانه ضمن السياق
العام للعمليات التي كانت تنفذها الفصائل
الفلسطينيه والتي سبق ونفذتها خلال
السنوات الماضيه ولكن بنظره اعم واشمل لا
يمكن فصل هذا التطور باي شكل من الاشكال
عن كافه التطورات التي كنا نشهدها ليس فقط
في الداخل الفلسطيني من خلال ما تقوم به
قوات الاحتلال بنسبه للاماكن المقدسه
والمصلين ولكن ايضا ضمن ربط متكامل لكل ما
شهدناه خلال الايام والاسابيع الماضيه من
استهدافات ومن قصف اسرائيلي كان يصادف
مواقع في داخل سوريا وادى الى سقوطها عدد
من القتلى في سواء من
المستشارين التابعين لحرس الثوري الايراني
وايضا من بعض الفصائل التابعه والمواليه
لايران وبالتالي ضمن كل هذا المشهد من
التازم في المنطقه جاء اطلاق الصواريخ
لذلك حمل دلالات كبيره على المستوى
اللبناني تواكب هذا الامر مع روايه
اسرائيليه مضخمه في بدايه الامر
عن 100 صاروخ وهو ما يوحي بان ثمه قرار
على المستوى الرسمي اللبناني والحزبي
وتحديدا يعني به حزب الله بانه قرر ان
ياخذ خطوه الى الامام المواجهه ولكن سرعان
ما تبين بان كل الارقام التي اوردتها
اسرائيل او الاعلام الاسرائيلي كانت ارقام
مضخمه وهنالك خشيه جديه في لبنان كانت في
اللحظات الاولى ما ان تقوم الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي تعاني من مازق داخلي
وتحديدا نتنياهو الذي يعاني من ما يعانيه
من انقسام داخليا على خيارات التي يمضي
بها في داخل اسرائيل ان يحاول الى تصدير
ازمته مجددا الى خارج اسرائيل من خلال
الايحاء بان اطلاق 100 صاروخ الى العمق
الاسرائيلي هو يعني ان ثمه من متغير على
مستوى المعادله التي تم ارساؤها بعد حرب
عام 2006 وبعد الاعتدال الاسرائيلي
والعضوان الاسرائيلي على لبنان وتم
ارسالها ايضا وتثبيتها خلال محطات عديده
منذ عام 2006 وصولا الى اليوم وبالتالي
ضمن هذه المعادله يتم قراءه كل هذه
التطورات ولكن من الواضح على مستوى
اللبناني بان هنالك شبه يقين محسوم بان ما
حصل يرتبط بقرار من فصائل فلسطينيه بان
تمد يد العون لاخوانهم في داخل فلسطين وفق
توصيفهم بطبيعه الحال نتيجه الاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه التي يواجهونها وبالتالي حتى
الان المعادله ما زالت ضمن الاطار العام
الذي كان مرسوما خلال السنوات الماضيه
وهما باتي يعرف هنا في لبنان وفي المنطقه
على نطاق واسع بانها معادله الردع
المتبادل والتي تقوم على الضوابط واضحه
وخطوط حمراء لا يقوم اي طرف بتجاوزها سواء
من قبل حزب الله او من قبل اسرائيل شهدنا
خلال الاعوام الماضيه عندما كانت تحصل
ذروه مواجهه على مستوى السياسي او على
مستوى ترسيم الحدود كانت الامور تنفرد
بشكل او باخر ضمن رد محدود سواء من خلال
اطلاق حزب الله لبعض الصواريخ واستهداف
بعض المنا العسكريه نتيجه ما كانت اسرائيل
تقوم من استهداف لعناصره او عندما جاء
موضوع ترسيم الحدود البحريه وترسيب
المنطقه الاقتصاديه الخالصه لبنان عندما
تم ارسال المسيرات الى عمق اسرائيلي ولكن
بقراءه شامله لا يبدو على المستوى
اللبناني بان ثمه متغير كبير على مستوى
القرار قرار حزب الله في المواجهه مع
اسرائيل وتحريك الجبهه الجنوبيه ولكن
بطبيعه الحال الجميع يترقب الان ما قد
تقوم به اسرائيل خلال الساعات المقبله ردا
على اطلاق هذه الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان